le conseil économique social et
environnemental de la culture et de
l'éducation de la martinique le ccm a
décidé le creux qui en sont ces une
commission ad' hoc chargée d'évaluer les
effets de la crise de coliques 19 pour
la martinique et surtout de penser le
monde après cette initiative et les deux
constats d'une banalité redoutable
si les superlatifs manquent au qualifié
cette crise il est au moins une
certitude si que les effets pour la
martinique seront démultipliés y très
largement amplifié comme malheureusement
c'est souvent le cas par conséquent
cette commission est écrit hier avec une
vocation transversale afin d'anticiper
les conséquences de la crise à court
moyen et long terme
il est vrai que pour le moment nous
avons la tête plongée dans le lit vide
on a fait le faire face aux effets de la
crise sur le plan sanitaire
mais très rapidement une réalité très
difficile va nous rattraper avec les
conséquences sur le plan économique
social culturel environnemental nous
faut donc d'ores et déjà réfléchir à ce
nouvel environnement qui va y corps à
l'issue de cette crise sanitaire
tous les changements que cela va
conduire et quelles solutions
on pourra y apporter